[Music]
here we go sushi samba is known for
their appreciation of food life and
celebrating with friends and they've
just opened an incredible addition here
to tell us about their new tree bar is
chef john um welcome to the show thank
you thank you for having me if someone's
watching they've never been to sushi
samba how would you describe your menu
our uh restaurant
is a celebration of japanese brazilian
and peruvian there's three cultures all
mixed together for one yeah like a
carnival like a party that's going on in
all the menus and then our artwork and
music and everything your food is so
good it's a party in your mouth i tell
you how much your food is delicious now
the tree bars opening the grand openings
tomorrow night this place is so
instagram worthy tell us more about the
tree bar tree bar we basically wanted to
reinvent our guest experience because
we've been open for over a decade and we
wanted to bring something new to our
guests with a brand new menu that comes
with it and also the brand new cocktail
menu as well that is just i mean the the
bar is stunning i see myself sitting
there on the weekend with some friends
having some sushi enjoying the
atmosphere and like i said your sushi
your food is amazing today we're going
to make a california roll yes
we are making california roll i wanted
to basically focus on our dedication on
picking our ingredients because not just
um plain crab meat we spend our time
picking
good nori seaweed the good rice and also
the good the king crab so i just wanted
to get to the basic and i want you to
show how to make this let's let's let's
do it i eat sushi every single friday
night my wife and i we love sushi i've
never made sushi before i got my gloves
on we've got what's the first thing we
need to do to make the perfect
california
right before you start just dab a little
bit
on the oil on your oils and your gloves
okay and then you have a rice on your
bowl right there and then just grab it
yes and then just in the middle of the
nori
and then just spread it out
yep just pretend like you're covering
all the black naughty part okay
you're covering okay cover it up use
your like fingertips to like transfer
over top and bottom perfect
all right
and then let me just try to yeah all
right now you know
you know you got to kind of have to make
it out and make it just spread out
evenly and then just grab this bottle of
sea sesame seeds and then sprinkle it
over season to taste there you go okay
and then flip it over
yep
and then put the ingredients and you
want to put
alaskan king crab in the middle of the
roll i mean it smells fresh i know it
tastes fresh it feels fresh too
and you don't want to over put it so you
don't um
so you can go ahead and close it gently
and nicely you know okay okay and then
put cucumber avocado however you want it
cucumber avocado making a california
roll here there you go sushi samba style
some avocado
all right
perfect
for some avocados
my roll is looking good you know chef i
know you've been uh how long i must be
very hungry right now i am starving
right now let me just correct a little
bit okay what's the next process here i
gotta wrap it in about 30 seconds i want
everyone to see my footage so
there you go and then just grab it to
the all the way bottom yes and then roll
it with a makitsu okay and tuck it in
tuck it in get in there come on get in
there there you go keep going that's a
big roll yeah all right and then let the
roll keep going and then release the
makitsu
okay this is how long you're making
sushi
about 20 years 20 years so 20 years
making sushi first time check this out
which which looks better
it's not bad it's not bad for the first
time but i'll tell you what i'll take
your sushi all day long chef john olm
thank you so much for joining us we
truly appreciate it and we look forward
to checking out the tree bar at sushi
samba thank you so much thank you las
vegas now we'll be right back